Hãy sẽ hành quân ngày Mỹ tăng thăm người thông báo đã bắt sửa một nghĩ phạm cầm đầu đường dây
lửa đạo tuyền dung ở đồng dân xa nước ngoài. Đối thửa ngoài 2 mi tội,
bị cá bột dụng giống nạn nhân bằng cách tin tuyền dung, việc nghệ lương cao.
Nhưng thực chất là lối kéo hợp, tham gia và có hành động phạm pháp như vận chuyển
tiền hoặc lửa đạo chực tuyền. Nhi phạm này được cho là câu két với một người đã nâm họ
hông. Đấy bắt sử chức đó, vì hỗ trợ các sâu sĩnh nâng bất ở pháp.
Nhà chứ chỉ khảnh quốc nghi ngờ đường dây này có linh quân đến vụ xinh ghê nước này,
bị phát hiện từ vóng ở khá buc gia hội tham tắm. Cương ngày, muu trinh bây đặc biệt được triển khai.
Để đưa sống với tư công dân hành quốc bị giám dữ tại khá buc gia về nước.
Zó có linh quân đến các hành động lửa đạo qua mạc.
Và các trường hợp này sẽ bị cậm dữ để phục vụ điều trà mưa dọc.